there was I don't know if you saw the
story there was some crazy story about
how we've discovered a way to reverse
aging by like 54% or something really
yeah it was 4% they did some kind of
plasma transfusion between mice and
found like ridiculous aging reversal
whoa so it's it's not peer-reviewed yet
and it's you know but these new yeah
it's new and they're saying that they
think it's like I was reading some
report from this guy on Twitter or some
PhD guy and he's like this looks legit
it's the goal now is to figure out what
in young plasma is causing cellular
repair yeah and then you get it you get
it you get a you get a pill oh man get
injection and then you'd basically be
like 28 forever good so that's the I
bring that up and also frightening maybe
a little yeah yeah dude watching altered
carbon yeah man I'm not on the richest
well getting richer and stay the same
age
no the question I guess is scary dude I
was watching this thing about
immortality okay and they said the only
reason we actually think immortality is
a bad thing is because we age and so
somebody who's 60 or 70 who has chronic
health problems it's like immortality
sucks right because we know that's in
our future most of us would say the same
thing alright but there was a the
arguments there are at Rp you could stay
for 28 years old
yeah then most people would prefer to
stay 28 forever okay even if it meant
like at 100 you would die but if you
were immortal it's like being young
forever you're healthy you're fine you
just want to keep living hmm I think
it's a bad thing though at least for now
but you know there's too much greed in
the world it's not about the greed it's
about human development like I you know
well and what what is stopping it from
from being what you would want it to be
greed you know what man
it's a sad reality but people die and
it's a good thing that's in terms of
like the the you know we pass on our
knowledge and our secrets to our youth
mmm-hmm who then get a new chance at
experiencing the world and developing
things and shaping things do I see it
the way the way they they see it and we
we we pass on so it's like we get our
time here to learn develop grow make the
changes we think and then we pass that
information down and that causes
evolution and development and you know
boundaries think about it this way a man
if a scientist from you-know-who was
born in the 1700s was alive today okay
he'd probably accept a bunch of things
that's true
but he'd have so many ingrained
falsehoods so it's like I was reading
about the discovery of Lex I think with
special relativity or maybe the Big Bang
okay and there's always a group of
scientists that reject the newer
theories and really really put scrutiny
you know scrutinize it I was talking to
this physicist guy about M theory which
is like it's like a I'm not super
familiar with it but a unified theory I
guess like a theory of the University of
everything okay and there's this guy
named I think his name is Garrett Lisi
who has the extremely simple theory of
everything this is all really old stuff
that's probably changed a whole lot but
I was talking to physicists who said
this is a problem in physics in that
these scientists have dedicated their
whole lives to this theory so that if it
turns out it's wrong their whole life
their work their legacies is wrong Wow
or they spent their entire life to
figure out that it was wrong but they
don't see it that way
think about I don't see it that way I
think like think about this way like you
you spend you know 10 years building
this very beautiful beautiful like model
house and then all of a sudden one day
it falls apart you didn't spend 10 years
to figure out that the final touch would
collapse you are trying to build this
beautiful house and now you're like
everything I've built has been you know
for nothing ok so they reject it it's
not even about whether or not they could
accept they were wrong and be like I've
successfully proven it false some people
do it's about them resisting and being
like III don't believe that
I don't believe no no no no no that's
economics and losing losing the science
part of it and it becoming like an
emotional investment rights you know
like part of their fundamentals you know
and it's like when you start off as a
scientist science you know it's all
about changing and learning and testing
and figuring out what works so if you
can't see that it works and it takes you
30 years to figure out that it doesn't
work then you're the scientist that did
it and if that's not what you're focused
on then then it's a fundamental issue
with with a human that is the scientist
you know I mean it's a human problem
yeah that's why I'm saying you know
somebody develops a theory mm-hmm then
you know they retire they die they've
had their time on earth
and then the younger person who is less
invested says hey wait a minute
this right here disproves that whoa and
now they develop and then you know less
less attachments so I'd imagine if if
humans were immortal and ever and you
know didn't die then there would be
cultural artifacts that would persist
that are like detrimental that make no
sense that maybe made sense at a certain
point Oh make sense now I think this
virus is like kind of shining a light on
how vulnerable we actually really are
because imagine if all the drugs in the
world and I mean drugs like vaccines and
everything we have the fight any ailment
that the human body goes through like
what if it all went away how many people
would actually die that you know how
many of us are actually strong enough to
survive at that point you know because
we're keeping humans alive for so long
now right I mean it's there's a tough
question man it's kind of crazy and like
what are we are we getting stronger or
are we getting weaker you know we're
kind of fending off like death like
human with our man-made stuff right
that's some dangerous that way there
Adam let's just stick to your work and
keep that mouth shut but that's what
that's what does that make me think of
like you were talking about us getting
stronger and like passing on our stuff
but we're like we're not passing on our
immunities we're passing on the the drug
that just kills the virus that would
have killed us that we don't have
immunity to anymore we've got we've got
a serious conundrum in our in
civilization
yeah and that's you know there's very
there you don't Fermi's paradoxes yeah I
feel like we've talked about it yeah so
which one of the paradoxes is it well
it's the I like the question of the
universe is so big why haven't we
discovered alien life oh right I'm
simplifying it but one of them I think
is that or that or that
there's definitely life out there that
support it basically the paradox is if
it's in all likelihood there is right so
why haven't we found them okay and
there's a bunch of you know proposed
answers I think one of them is very
simple we evolved in a way to survive
but once we've conquered our survival
then these things actually become
extremely detrimental when you have ten
people living in the wilderness together
yeah doing everything in our power to
save someone's life is crucial to the
success of the tribe when you have seven
point six billion people doing
everything to ensure that literally
everyone survives becomes eventually
detrimental in certain ways yeah so we
see the persistence of genetic diseases
that you know we've basically separated
ourselves from this now we're smart
enough to actually get rid of some of
these diseases and start improving us so
I don't know if it's necessarily like
night pro or con in in in in many
aspects but I think it is true that
we're at a weird point where it is an
ethical moral conundrum when you have
people who provide nothing to the
greater the greater society in terms of
survivability yeah actually become net
detriments to it and a lot of we are
they have no choice you know they're not
yeah the people not everyone has even
the chance or ever will have the chance
to help Society further itself because
the society is it's not even it's huge
can you are you alive you know I mean
like so it's a it's a conundrum of if we
were a tribe of 30 people yeah and there
was someone who was like a vegetable
okay like people would like in a coma
like you're totally brain-dead okay yeah
what are they gonna do III don't know
cuz it's nothing there could be
resourceful if we were a tribe in the
middle of the woods they probably died
you can't feed them right they would die
so we've been detected invented
technology to provide nutrients to
sustain someone who's literally just
consuming resources and energy because
we have a moral obligation to protect
life right that's a challenge it is
because I certainly think we should save
the lives yeah you know I mean money
talk about the money
I mean who's we well yeah you say we got
the money it's like but then that
hospital that save it costs fifty
thousand to keep someone on a respirator
and being fed with catheter system what
all the whole glad I you definitely want
to say something right now go what
better use of public funds uh-huh as
moral people do we have than taking care
of people who can't take care of
themselves through no fault of their own
I know it's so easy to say that what
that is not the way it is yeah I know
it's in the perfect
world right what meant more money
killing figuring out ways to kill people
what happens when the Zenit axons come
from the Galactic Federation they start
fire bombing our oil fields and now
we're like we need we need hospital beds
for the for the wounded what do we do
you got triage do we kick those people
out of the hills yeah you would have to
that's the point of making yeah so it's
like right now at peace yeah we have a
moral obligation to save all life so
they're like therapy's there are some
people who have never had a a thought in
their lives
yeah it's true and I know so I know some
people who have family members who were
born with severe mental disabilities
yeah
don't speak are considered to be on the
vert like essentially comatose or like
severely developmentally disabled you
know and they are legally obligated and
morally obligated to do everything they
can to keep you know to save this life
and I agree but I also recognize that
the potential philosophical conundrum I
guess when it comes to a real conflict
yeah we're not gonna provide resources
for these these people and we're already
there aren't we didn't we have like the
do not resuscitate orders the people the
doctors that were like that person's
dead this person's more important save
them instead of them well that's just
that happened in Italy that happened
here right it but it's already happened
yeah so we're already past that point
and the crazy if the craziest thing
about it is that most of our hospitals
weren't overrun make up right here
hospitals that were overrun and so that
resulted in being ladies this hospital
we can't do it so you die breath yeah
what do you do man what do you do I
don't know I'm glad I was not a doctor
in that situation and to make that
choice when you go too far to the
extremes you end up with no good answer
right you know you go full fascist and
they're like unplug them and you go too
far left and they're like don't unplug
them and don't provide resources to
those who truly need it right it's like
the yeah it's like logic versus emotion
I guess yeah and man it's tough if you
lose your emotion you become a robot
nobody wants to be the Borg yes but if
you lose your logic you become just like
you collapse you can't function properly
right exactly right
exactly yep man so I guess the the
somehow we got into this conversation
talking about immortality yeah how do we
get here
cuz I was talking about like scientific
development or something right and we
talked about immortality that's one that
was great it was deep questions you're
just hitting them up though that's nice
so here's my question and yeah would you
take immortality if the vampire lestat
walked in right now it was literally Tom
Cruise absolutely no hesitation that was
a great book by the way the book yeah
I've seen the movie spot the book list
oh the star I've seen interview with a
vampire yeah but would you would you
also a good book
vampire thing aside that's silly but uh
yeah we should take immortality man I
don't know I mean my I would want to say
yes because I would love to you know see
the civilization civilization in the
future where we colonized it
you know this whole solar system travel
around go to the different planets see
it all and and that I mean I think about
Star Trek was one of my favorite shows
when you asked me if I would want to be
immortal the first thing I think of is
oh man I could travel the Stars then I
can actually travel the universe and not
have to worry about dying but are we
talking about biological immortality
where you just don't age more like your
Wolverine invincible you know
regenerating and you can't literally
can't die I'll take that yeah that
sounds good what happened at the heat
death of the universe man don't last
forever they'll be just floating around
in all didn't didn't Wolverine die well
but yet but I'm talking about spoiler I
got if you could look to meet though I
don't remember did he or not I'm using
him as a just like an example what I
mean is I will become immortal if I have
the choice to kill myself eventually
that's what I was gonna say but I'd say
yes how about now because then I'd be
like hundred years from now I'd be like
that was fun seppuku oh what a way to go
that Korean it's like actually you heart
Japanese you have to slice off your left
ankle what the one weakness is your
abilities yeah it's like well it's time
to go I let me get that
just flick it well you could buy you
know order hey hold on man my ankles are
screaming you're very idealistic because
maybe I what if the future isn't we
explore the Stars it's a bunch of SJW
start locking people in gulags and they
said Harry Caray look what Harry Caray
isn't that another term for it
Harry Caray Mary Kerry is the guy from
the Cubs yeah I don't know I don't know
seppuku Harry Caray seppuku
Harry Harry Caray was the guy who talked
like this and it's like a Cubs announcer
also also what it is the same thing
that's a similar like suicidal Harry
Caray
yeah it's called it's spelled har i ka
RI o how do you tell you howdy oh excuse
me
yeah excuse me you're from Chicago's of
course I know but funny thing is I'm
from Chicago too so whenever I say it I
think of him doing it I loved him man he
was he was hilarious I went I went and
saw him a bunch of he's the announcer
for the Cubs Wrigley Field while he was
wrestle for many many years and Wrigley
Field in Chicago so us growing up in
Chicago like we think Harry Caray and
it's this like well I'm Harry Caray
spoke like this this is funny come on
man yeah I ask you another question
oh please what about these what-if
questions well they couldn't preserve
your body but they could preserve your
consciousness digital in a stack no no
like in a virtual like when you get
basically like in exact and ultra carbon
what no no black mirror okay I don't
know what it's when they when they go to
retire and kinder like 80 okay they
download their brains into a server
we're also in their into 20s and they're
in digital retires yeah did see that
episode
now you're young and you're partying and
you're like doing forever yeah so I mean
it sounds good I don't know I mean do I
have any say or can anyone have any say
on the outside world or once you're in
there you're like cut off I guess well
no that's a big difference like you can
still communicate with people because
they come visit you they can come in
hang on the server interesting this is
their Futurama episode I'm surprised you
didn't go Futurama with that
know the future I'm one of things
they're like just comatose or something
they're like in a library of retirement
where they're like plugged no I think
world yeah it is the first row but the
the the the black mirror one was that's
more shot on yeah yeah yeah yeah because
yeah Juniper yes and Santa junipers yes
I'm like island yeah they're like
partying and stuff and they're like
young forever I think it'd be weird
because you'd have like one server
that's the 19th like you people born in
the 1920s yeah and there's like all
super racist and like very like
traditional okay and so then you
wouldn't mix the people who were born in
the 70s who are all like you know
whoa whoa whoa I know a lot of my I have
a lot of older cousins that were born in
the 70s they were definitely hippies
well their parents were hippies too so
it kind of boomers were hippies okay the
people born in the 50s who were late
teenagers in the 70s
yeah bees yeah I read something crazy I
read that Woodstock there's a pandemic
during Woodstock but they're really yeah
flu pandemic yeah and they're like
nobody cared they like it's because it
only affected older people right and so
the question was then it's like I think
this was like some Economic Council
they're like if that's the case man
we've I don't think they made this
argument but it's kind of like we
prioritize safety isn't that kind of
what's going what we're finding out
about kovat it's kind of it's killing
all these older folk that were already
at risk if they've gotten the flu
they're probably died also people would
know vitamin D yeah Oh get outside get
some sunshine more often but they tell
you to stay inside and now there's this
whole thing about like kids are there's
this new thing that's going around
inflammatory syndrome it sounds like a
scare tactic honestly does man it sounds
like they're trying to continue on its
us to go to them yeah nothing happening
right nothing happened so first I don't
know South Dakota never locked down and
the media attacked them relentlessly and
then they still refused and now it's
it's three weeks on from when they were
being attacked the media was like South
Dakota the new hot spot there weeks
later nothing and of course they're not
talking about it right
that part's like no no don't talk about
it meanwhile Los Angeles like we must
lock down indefinitely until there's a
cure for virus yeah and no wonder that
the Republican just won in California
didn't there so this is exactly what
went down that district ok thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune into this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you